hello, student nurses.
I'm student nurse bail
for today I will be presenting to you
on how I compete Ivy solution.
so you're not going to a shortcut pedal?
you need to follow parign young formula, nah?
so we have number one 1000 ML doctors ordered the plane
nss to be infused at 8 hours another factor is 15 15.
so ML per hour and drops per minute.
so potama oil ML per hour. 1000 ML divided by 8 hours.
we have one 25 ML per hour.
so what about not in the oil drops per minute.
so on the factor nothing is 15.
so Elon 15 and matter to 60.
so 60รท15 we have 4 so you know 131.25 or 31
drops per minute so etoning so good so at you
so second we have 800 and melt of infused
in 4 hours the doctor is 20
so doing nothing shortcut so 800
ML divided by 4 hours
so divided by Elon mueron
20 to 60 so 60 divided by 20
we have 3 so divided by 3 so 80 divided by
800 ML divided by 4 we have 200 ML per hour
and 200 divided by 3 we will get 66.66 or 67
drops per minute
so I think the regulate more 67 drops per minute so
finally answer number 3 doctors order is 1000 ML
to be infused in 12 hours and then make the drop shot
so what is the milk per hour and what is the drops
per minute. thank you
and god bless.